خطه تغيير نظام القضائي في اسرائيل مشروع
طرحه رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو قلب
الشارع راسا على عقب ابقى الاسرائيليين في
الشوارع لاسابيع لكن ما هي خطه تغيير نظام
القضائي نتنياهو يسعى لتقليص سلطات
المحكمه العليا ومنح السياسيين سلطات اكبر
باختيار القضاه عبر اجراءات تهدف كما يقول
الى اعاده التوازن الى فروع السلطه
الحكومه تتهم قضاه المحكمه العليا بانهم
سيسون ويتمتعون بسلطه اعلى من تلك التي
يتمتع بها نواب الكنيسه البرلمان وافق في
قراءه اولى على بندين اساسيين في الخطه
الاول يغير عمليه تعيين القضاه والثاني
يجعل المحكمه العليا غير مؤهله لالغاء اي
تعديل للقوانين الاساسيه التي تعد بمثابه
في اسرائيل اما البندول اكثر جدلا فيقضي
بادخال بند الاستثناء الذي يسمح للبرلمان
الغاء بعض القرارات المحكمه العليا
بغالبيه بسيطه تبلغ واحدا 61 صوتا من اصل
120 عضوا في البرلمان من جهه اخرى معارضوه
المشروع يعتبرون الخطه ترمي الى تقويد
السلطه القضائيه لصالح السلطه السياسيه
محذرين من انه يشكل تهديدا لنظام
الديمقراطي برمته كما اتهمت المعارضه
نتنياهو بالسعي الى تحقيق مصالحه الشخصيه
من خلال هذا التعديل لاسقاط تهم الفساد
التي وجهها اليه القضاء